you're coming into a very iconic crew
and there was a lot of drama that went
down when Roseanne Barr her departure
happened what was the hardest part about
joining a crew that was already somewhat
established joining a crew that's
already established we do feel like the
odd man out a little bit and you but you
also want to allow people the
opportunity to grieve or to feel or to
heal whatever the case may be you don't
want to disrupt their process but you
also want them to embrace the change and
I was the change so I would just say we
just took baby steps I mean it's just
over the course of the season we've all
gotten much more comfortable and
familiar with each other and now it
feels like a family unit that's really
good to hear who was the first one from
the cast to really welcome you and make
you feel at home Sara Gilbert because
she hand-picked me and I'm extremely
thankful and grateful for that
opportunity she took someone who was
unknown to everyone else I'm not new to
this you know exact and said I believe
in her and let's give her this
opportunity yeah and you were prepared
so yes you're prepared at preparation
meets opportunity we know this thing I
have an announcement I'm having a baby a
baby what I know Becky now has a baby on
the way on the way and that is also
gonna be without a grandmother so I
would imagine there's probably some
advice Roseanne but want to pass on like
how are you guys gonna tackle this new
addition I'd love to be able to have the
opportunity to have the disciplines mesh
or not mesh with the raising of all of
the children right and so I'd like to
see how all of the Conners probably have
different ways of raising not just the
Connor way and the Williams counter way
yeah let's see how we bring together
it's a family I mean that's but
conflicts equals comedy yeah right so
and it's nothing that the family can't
handle together what I'm looking forward
to is more of the family time well then
we'll get the whole family to help out
Becky we're not gonna let your baby fall
through the cracks can you talk to me
about whether we're going to explore
DJ's family die
in future episodes that is the goal
right now because there was a little bit
of history and backstory of Jeana in the
past even though I'm new to you the
character has been around for decades
okay so what we're looking forward to is
more DJ and Gina family time soon okay
so obviously we know this this is a
mixed family dynamic are we going to
explore that specific topic when it
comes to DJ's family well that's the
goal I mean I'm not a writer I'm not one
of the writers on the show we don't have
all of our scripts yet yeah so there is
still time tonight is Mary Skype call
with Gina it's on Afghanistan time so
it's 2:00 a.m. here okay and being an
active duty soldier it just makes me
think are we going to have you be
deployed at any point is that likely or
you are we putting this out to the
universe out but I mean if you're active
duty just raises questions you know
interestingly enough she is currently a
recruiter on the base so she's come back
from Afghanistan what I think I'd like
for us to focus on is maybe what it's
like for her being active duty but still
being with her family excuse me in
Afghanistan there might be some PTSD
there might be some definite
disciplinary issues that she has with
how the Conners have been raising Mary
okay and I'd also like us to delve more
into Mary being a biracial child growing
up and being raised by the white half
yeah of her family so now the both
hesitancy that I think we should focus
right so now she has to really embrace
the other half of her family and you're
introducing that Roseanne od'd on
opioids possible talk about the the
tragic death of Roseanne on the show how
has everyone on set been feeling and
grieving since having a loss of her I
know there was this whole debacle with
Roseanne the person but just Roseanne
from the show how is how is Gina helping
everyone cope once you lose someone in
your family right Roseanne the character
or Rose and
the person everybody kind of moves and
takes on different roles right to kind
of feel the void yeah
so to speak you can never completely
fill a void and she I find her to be an
amazing artist like I said I grew up
watching this show and I actually
watched season 9 or season 10 as well so
I just think everyone's learning how to
adjust to their new roles in the family
what's been the reaction people have had
to your character has been positive
negative I think it's funny to people
that I am the conservative voice on the
show and I think that it's interesting
to people that way that I don't have a
problem no I don't have a problem
communicating what I want to say even
though I am a Conor by marriage does
that make sense yes no I understand
sometimes in-laws they take a step back
energetic Lee to Len Gina doesn't yeah
she comes full force he comes for for
how long two years two years that's
almost the whole time I was gone